-Guys, it's time to take a look
at these stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons
of easing COVID guidelines.
That's right.
Lots of places are starting to
relax their COVID restrictions.
People are traveling more.
So let's take a look at
the pros and cons
of easing COVID guidelines.
Here we go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't tell me.
Spoiler.
No spoiler.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
I mean, it just...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Be careful.
-Safe is sexy.
-Just be careful.
-Don't do it.
It's just beads.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Ah...
Yeah, I'll be there."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Smoky-eyed rando?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like, yeah...
"He never plays this!"
Yeah, well...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a good costume.
-Sexy doctor.
-And, finally...
[ Cheers ]
There you go, everybody.
That's "Pros and Cons."